very often we call in French leaders
those who are simply dictators now
history tells us that it's all about the
prize the country pays for dismantling
the dictatorship and for removing these
bad guys from their offices I don't
think that Putin is so much entrenched I
don't think that he has so much support
it's very much his powers very much
based on the apathy of the population
which is natural probably after to
Malta's years you know followed the
collapse of the Soviet Union and of
course the lack of the reasonable
alternative so oil prices were high the
root of Russian ruling elite could
benefit from that tons of money was
quote-unquote earned you know in fact
stolen by those who are in power most of
this money was invested outside of
Russia so it's it's it's quite an
amazing probably you know
psychologically thick situation as
psychotic form of psychological sickness
while Russian elite talking about
nationalism patriotism opposing you know
the Western influence while keeping
everything the money the fortunes are
sending their kids to the very country
they so so harshly criticized I think
it's it's it's just a matter of time and
and most important matter of price
because the social revolt in Russia is
inevitable I can only hope that the
values that will make a core of this
revolt will not be so far from democracy
as it can happen if putin's rules
continue it's not that Putin it can
offer us any guarantee against
ultra-nationalists taking over to the
contrary longer he stays in power more
chances that the revolt will be
absolutely wild and it will be
non-democratic well today we still have
a chance of bringing Russia back to
Europe back to this European
civilization and and and and and using
still enormous potential of my country
to strengthen democratic institutions
are on the global scale
you